[MUSIC PLAYING]
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Hello,
and welcome to the security
zone here at Google Next.
We're here with Maya, an expert
in infrastructure security.
Thanks for being here, Maya.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Thank
you for having me, Cassie.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So I'm
so glad that you're here
because I would love
to know more about how
you provide security for
users and employees at Google.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Of course.
By some accounts, Google's
network delivers more than 25%
of internet traffic.
So our infrastructure
is super critical,
and security is one of
our highest priorities
for that global infrastructure.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So if
I'm running a business,
how do I use Google Cloud
infrastructure to protect
my data?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Let's
walk through an example.
To start off, say you upload
a file into Google Drive
from your Pixelbook.
So I have this photo of
a really cute dog here,
and I want to save
that for later.
So I'll just drag that into
Google Drive, and it uploads.
And that happened super fast.
But let's break down what
happened to that file
and how it was
secured along the way.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Let's do it.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: So when you
connect to a Google service
over the internet, Google
requires that the connection
is encrypted.
That means the data
that you sent to Google
will be encrypted in
transit so it can't be read
by a malicious third party.
Connections to Google
services come into our network
through Google
front end servers,
which terminate your connection
and provide encryption
using the HTTPS protocol.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So my data is
encrypted in transit to Google
without me having
to do anything?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Yeah, that's right.
The Google front end
also routes your request
to the right service.
So once it's inside
Google's infrastructure,
your data travels over
our network backbone
and might go to
another location.
Let's say that in your case,
to reach its destination,
your file travels across a
Google-owned undersea cable.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: You
mean one of these things.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Exactly.
Those are undersea cables
that we have under the sea.
And so you'll see there
there's a fiber optic cable
right in the middle surrounded
by multiple layers of steel.
And they even have shark-proof
armor and rubber coverings,
because that's an issue
that we have to encounter.
Google operates one of
the largest backbone
networks in the world.
It connects our data centers
with hundreds of thousands
of miles of fiber optic cable.
The blue lines here represent
the current Google network,
and the green lines
indicate new network cables
that Google's developing.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So the file's
been encrypted in transit
to Google's network
and then sent
to the right place over
Google's global private network.
So what happens
to the file next?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Next,
we'll store the file
that you uploaded on
one of Google servers.
Customer content stored
by Google Cloud Services,
like Google Drive, is
encrypted at rest by default.
Here's how that works.
The file that we uploaded
is first chunked--
broken up into pieces.
And each chunk is encrypted with
its own data encryption key.
Each data encryption key is then
wrapped using a key encryption
key, which is stored centrally.
The encrypted chunks
and their keys
are distributed across
Google's storage infrastructure
for security and reliability.
If your file is updated.
it's re-encrypted
with a new key rather
than re-using the existing key.
As a result of this
process, if a bad actor
wanted to access data,
they would not only
need all the pieces of the
file, which are spread out
across multiple servers,
but they would also
need access to all of the keys.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So the file
is automatically encrypted
at rest on Google servers.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: That's
right, without you
having to take any action.
Let's take a look into the
servers protecting the file
and how they're protected.
We design our own hardware
at Google, as well as
our own software, to make sure
that we have complete control
over our infrastructure.
Google's servers contain a
custom Google Titan security
chip.
Titan helps to make sure
that no unauthorized machines
or software operate
on our network.
If Titan is not
present or Titan can't
verify the integrity
of the server software,
the server will not boot.
That means a
malicious actor can't
start up a fake
service, for example,
and get access to your data.
If everything is as
expected, the machine
comes online and is
ready for action.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: This
is a real Titan chip.
There are chips like
these in servers
across Google's
infrastructure that
protect Google's servers, like
the one I uploaded a file to.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
These servers sit
in Google-owned data centers.
The physical security
of these data centers
is yet another
level of protection.
Google data centers include
metal detectors, secure access
cards, and biometric scanners.
Data centers are monitored 24/7
by high resolution interior
and exterior cameras,
have large fences--
some threatening
local wildlife like
alligators in some locations--
and vehicle access barriers
to protect unauthorized
entrance into the data center.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So let's
summarize the whole thing,
then.
The file we uploaded
is encrypted in transit
when it's traveling outside
our physical boundaries,
encrypted at rest by
default, and protected
in Google-designed and -owned
servers, security chips,
and data centers.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Exactly.
And millions of files are
being uploaded every day
to Google Cloud that
are being protected
by this global infrastructure.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV:
Well, thanks, Maya,
for taking us through
the journey a file takes
as it makes its way
securely from the device
to the data center.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: My pleasure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]